let's say we have the same path that we
had in the last video
draw my y-axis
that is my x-axis
and let's say the path looks like this
it looks something like this it's the
same one we had in the last video might
not look exactly like it let me see what
i did in the last video it looked like
that in the last video but close enough
let's say we're dealing with the exact
same curve as the last video we could
call that curve c
now the last video we dealt with a with
a vector field that only had vectors in
the i direction let's deal with another
vector field that only has vectors in
the
j direction or the vertical direction so
let's say that
q the vector field q of x y
it's equal to capital q of x y
times j
and we are going to concern ourselves
we're going to concern ourselves with
the closed line integral around the path
c
of
q
of q
dot d r
and we've seen it already d r
dr
can be rewritten as
dx times i plus d y times j
so if we were to take the dot product of
these two this
this line integral is going to be the
exact same thing this is going to be the
same thing
as the closed line integral over c of q
dot dr well q only has a j component so
if you take it's 0 i so 0 times dx
that's just 0 and then you're going to
have q x y
times d y they had no i component so
this is just going to be q
you could switch to the same color again
q
of x and y
times d y that's the dot product there
was no i component that's why we don't
we lose the dx now let's see if there's
any way that we can solve this line
integral without having to resort to a
third parameter t just like we did in
the last video it's actually we'll do it
it'll be almost identical we're just
dealing with y's now instead of x's so
we can do is we could say well what's
our minimum y and our maximum y so our
minimum y let's say it's right here
it's a minimum y let's call that
a let's say our maximum y
that we attain is right over there
let's call that b
oh and just like in the last i forgot to
tell you the direction of the curve but
this is the same path as last time so
we're going in a counterclockwise
direction this the exact same curve
exact same path
exact same path so we're going in that
direction
now in the last video we broke it up
into two functions of x's two y as a
function of x now we want to deal with
y's let's break it up into two functions
of y
so if we break this path into two paths
let's let's go that's our those are kind
of our extreme points let's call this
path
right here
let's call that path right there
let's call that y
let's call that x of so here along this
path x is equal to
i could just write
i could write this path 2 or i'll call
it c 2
we could say it's x
is equal to x two of y that's that path
and then the first path
all right it doesn't have to be the
first path depending where you start you
can start anywhere let's say this one in
magenta we'll call that path 1 and we
could say
that that's defined as x is equal to x1
of y it's a little confusing when you
have x as a function of y but it's
really completely analogous to what we
did in the last video we're literally
just swapping x's and y we're now
expressing x as a function of y instead
of y as a function of x so we have these
two curves you can imagine just flipping
it and we're doing the exact same thing
that we did in the last video just now
in terms of y but if you look at it this
way this
line integral can be rewritten
this could be rewritten as being equal
to
the integral
the integral well let's just do
c2 first let's just do c2 first this is
the integral from b to a
we start at b and we go to a right this
is we're coming back from a high y to a
low y
the integral from b
to a
of
q of
of doing that gray color
of q of instead of having an x there we
know along this curve right here x is
equal to we want everything in terms of
y so here x is equal to x 2 of y
so q of x2 of y
x2
of y
comma y maybe i'm using too many colors
here but i think you get the idea
d y
d y
so this is the part of the line integral
just over this left-hand curve and then
we're going to add to that
we're going to add to that the line
integral
the line integral or really just the
regular integral now from y is equal to
a to y is equal to b
y is equal to a to y is equal to b
of
q
of
instead of x being equal to x 2 now x is
equal to x 1 of y it's equal to this
curve this other function
so x 1
of y
x 1 of y comma y
d y and we can do exactly what we did in
the previous video instead of we don't
like the larger number on the bottom so
let's swap these two around so if you
swap these two if you make this into an
a and this into a b that makes it the
negative of the integral when you swap
the two
change the direction
this is exactly what we did in the last
video so hopefully it's nothing too
fancy but now that we have the same
boundaries of integration these two
definite integrals we can just write
them as one definite integral so this is
going to be equal to the integral
from a
to b and i'll write this one first since
it's positive
of
all right in this one q
of x 1 of y
comma y
minus
this one right we have the minus sign
here minus
q
of x2 of y
and y
d y
let me do that in that neutral color
d y
and that's multiplied by all of these
things i distributed out the d y i think
you get the idea this is identical to
what we did in the last video and this
could be rewritten as this is equal to
the integral from a
to b
of and inside of the integral we're
evaluating the function q of
x
y
from
the boundaries
the upper boundary
where
the upper boundary
is going to be from x is equal to x1 of
y
and the lower boundary
is
x is equal to x2 of y right all the x's
we substitute it with that and then we
get some expression and then from that
we subtract this with x substituted as
x2 of y that's exactly what we did and
just like i said in the last video we're
going kind of the reverse direction that
we normally go in definite integrals we
normally get to this and then the next
step is we get this but now we're going
in the reverse direction but it's all
the same difference
and all of that times d y
all of that times d y and just like we
saw in the last video this let me do an
orange
this expression right here actually let
me draw that d y a little further out so
it doesn't get all congested
let me do that d y
out here
this expression
this entire expression
is the same exact thing
that entire expression is the exact same
thing as the integral
the integral from
x is equal to
x is equal to i can just write it here
let me write in the same colors
x x2 of y
to x1 of y
to x
1 of y
of
of the partial i'll do it in the i'll
stay in that orange color of
the partial of q
with respect
to x
dx
this
i want to make it very clear this is at
least in my mind the first part you know
when i first saw it a little confusing
but if you look just saw an integral
like this if this is the inside of a
double integral and it is the outside is
what we saw there is the integral
from a
to b
d
y
but if you just saw this in a double
integral what you would do is you would
take the anti-derivative of this the
anti-derivative of this with respect to
x the anti-derivative of the partial of
q with respect to x with respect to x is
going to be just q of x y and then you
since it's a definite integral you would
evaluate it at x1
of y and then subtract from that this
function evaluated x2 of y which is
exactly what we did so hopefully you
appreciate that and then we got our
result which is very similar to the last
result what is what does this double
integral represent
what does it represent it represents
well anything if you have any double
integral that goes from
if you imagine this is some function let
me draw it in three dimensions this is
really almost a review of what we did in
the last video if that's the y-axis
that's our x-axis that's our z-axis this
is some function of of x and y so some
surface you could imagine
on the x-y plane
it's some surface
so we could call that
the partial of q
with respect to x
and what this double integral is this is
a this is essentially defining a region
and you can kind of view this dx times
dy is kind of a small differential of
area so the region under question the
boundary points are from y going from
y goes from at the bottom it goes from
x2 of y which we saw was a curve that
looks something like this that's the
lower y and over here if we draw in two
dimensions this was the lower y curve
the upper y curve is x one of y
so the upper y curve
looks something like that
the upper y curve goes something like
that so x varies from the lower y curve
to the upper y curve right that's what
we're doing right here
and then y varies from a to b
and so this is essentially saying let's
take the double integral over this
region
over this region right here
of this function of this function so
it's essentially the volume if this is
the ceiling and this boundary is
essentially the wall it's the volume of
that room and i don't know what it would
look like when it comes up here but you
can kind of imagine something like that
it would be the volume of that so that's
what we're taking
this is the identical result we got in
the last video and this is a pretty neat
thing so all of a sudden
this vector that and q of x y i didn't
draw it out like i did the last time
this vector of xy only has things in the
j direction so it only has if i were to
draw it's a vector field it only has the
vectors only go up and down
the vectors only
go up and down like that they have no
horizontal component to them but what we
saw when you start with a vector field
like this you take
the line integral around this closed
loop and i'll rewrite it like right here
you take this line integral around this
closed loop of q
dot d r which is equal to the integral
around the closed loop
of q
of x y
d y
we just figured out that that's
equivalent to the double integral
the double integral over the region over
the region this is the region
right that's exactly what we're doing
over here if i just give you the region
you have to define it you say well x is
going from this is going from this
function that function and y is going
from a to b and you might want to review
the double integral videos if that
confuses you so we're taking the double
integral over the region
of the partial of q
with respect to x
d well you could write d x d y or you
could even write a little d a right the
differential of area right that's we
could imagine it's a d a which is the
same thing as a d x d y and if we
combine that with the last video and
this is kind of the neat bringing it all
together apart
the result of the last video was this
that if i had a function that's defined
completely in terms of x
we had this right here we had that
result actually let me copy and paste
both of these to a nice clean part of my
whiteboard and then we can
we can do the
exciting conclusion
so let me copy and paste that
so that's what we got in the last video
and in this video in this video we got
this result i'll actually just copy and
paste that part right there
you might
already predict where this is going
and then let me paste it over here this
is the result from this video
now let's think about a arbitrary vector
field that is defined as
let's say i have an arbitrary vector
field i'll do it in pink let's say f
is a vector field defined over the x y
plane and f is equal to p
of x y
i
plus q
of x y
j you can almost imagine f being the
addition of our vector fields p and q
that we did in the last two videos q was
this video and we did p in the video
before that but this is really any
arbitrary vector field
and let's say we wanted to take the
vector field or sorry the line integral
of this vector field along some path it
could be the same one we've done which
has been a very arbitrary one so it's
really any arbitrary path so let me draw
some arbitrary path over here
so let's say that is my arbitrary path
my arbitrary curve let's say it goes in
that
clockwise counterclockwise direction
just like that and i'm interested in
what
the line integral the closed line
integral around that path of
f
dot dr is and we've seen it multiple
times
dr
is equal to dx times i plus dy
times j so this line integral can be
rewritten as
this is equal to
the line integral around the path c f
dot dr that's going to be this term
times dx so that's p
of x y times dx
plus
this term q of x y times d y
and this whole thing this is you could
put this is the same thing as you could
essentially this is the same thing as
the line integral
of p of x y
dx plus the line integral
of q of x y
d y now what are these things this is
what we figured out in the first video
this is what we figured out just now in
this video this thing right here
is the exact same thing as that over
there
so this
is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
the double integral over the region over
this region
right here of
the minus partial of p with respect to y
the minus partial of p
with respect to y instead of a d y d x
we could say just you know over the
differential of area
and then plus
this one this result q this thing right
here is exactly what we just proved is
exactly what we just showed in this
video
so that's plus i'll leave it up there
maybe i'll do it in the yellow plus the
double integral over the same region of
the partial of q with respect to x
d a
where that's just d y d x or d x d y you
can switch the order it's the
differential of area
and now we can add these two integrals
what do we get so this is equal to and
this is kind of our big grand conclusion
maybe magenta is called for here
the double integral of over the region
of i'll write this one first because
it's positive that one's negative of the
partial of q
with respect to x
minus the partial of p
with respect to y
d
the differential of area this is our big
takeaway
this is our big takeaway let me write
here
over the close the line integral of the
closed loop of f
dot dr is equal to the double integral
of this expression and it's something
you know just to remember we're taking
the the the the function that was
associated with the x component or the i
component we're taking the partial with
respect to y
and the the function that was associated
with the y component we're taking the
partial with respect to x and that first
one we're taking the negative of that's
a good way to remember it but this
result right here this is
maybe i should write it in green
this is
greens
this is green's
theorem
green's theorem and it's a neat way to
relate a line integral of a vector field
that has these partial derivatives
assuming it has these partial
derivatives to
the region to a double integral of the
region now and this is a little bit of a
side note we've seen in several videos
before if f is conservative
we've learned that if
f
is
conservative
conservative which means it's the
gradient of some function that it's path
independent that the closed integral
around any path
is equal to zero and that's still true
so that tells us that if f is
conservative this thing right here
must be equal to zero that's the only
way that you're always going to enforce
that this whole integral is going to be
equal is going to be equal to zero over
any any any region i mean you could
think of situations where they cancel
each other out but really over any
region that's the only way that this is
going to be true that these two things
are going to be equal to zero so then
you could say
partial of q with respect to x minus the
partial of p with respect to y has to be
equal to zero or these two things have
to equal each other
or this kind of a corollary to green's
theorem kind of a low hanging fruit you
could have figured out the partial of q
with respect to x is equal to the
partial of p
with respect to y
and when you study exact equations in a
differential equation you'll see this a
lot more and actually well i won't go
into too much but conservative fields
are actually the the the differential
form of what you see in the line
integral is actually if it's
conservative would be an exact equation
but we're not going to go into that too
much but hopefully you might see the
parallels if you've already run into
exact equations in differential
equations but this is the big takeaway
and let's maybe do some examples using
this takeaway
in the next video